As a member of the committee of
the Southern Nevada Health District, we have seen
an increase in positive cases in Kobe
in the Latino community, especially in
the zip code, they are 89,110 and this has been going on
since the committee began right now, no, it
has not decreased more, however
the numbers have increased that has us
a little dismayed because we
want the community to take steps to
prevent kobe and how do we do
it if we don't feel well we are
around people who we know have been
identified as positive we have to
get tested so that we can
protect and protect our
families and what we have to be
really aware of is that
although young people don't have much to do with
Kobe, it is something that our body will be
able to tolerate and we will be able to
cope with our
elderly people, we don't  goes so well
usually they require
hospitalizations and they
really could be debating their life
between life and death and what  We want to
protect our elderly people,
so it is very
important that we as leaders
look for where to bring more tests for
the population in that zip code that is
highly Latino in our community